hi this is an interview with jacob
steinhardt who is the author of a blog
post series called more is different for
ai more is different is the title of a
famous paper in science from 1972 by
philip warren anderson a nobel prize
winner in physics the article is
generally on the theme of emergent
phenomenon when scaling things up so as
you make things bigger not only does
stuff get just more as you would expect
but qualitatively new phenomena arise
you know what better phenomenon to
discuss in this context than a.i so
today we'll talk to jacob about this
blog post series expect to learn how
scale fundamentally changed how we look
at ai systems how the paper clip
maximizer might not be as dumb of a
thought experiment and how we can look
forward and make sense of a world where
ai safety could play a critical role in
how we interact with these systems in
the future now i'm having a ton of fun
talking to people about all kinds of
stuff but ultimately what matters is you
so please let me know how i can make
these videos the best possible for you
leave a comment share them around if you
like them and let's get into it
hello everyone today i have jacob
steinhardt here with me who authored a
series of blog posts titled more is
different for a.i which lays out an
argument or a series of arguments uh
playing out the
i want to say the different viewpoints
on the future of ai alignment and safety
in ai safety in machine learning systems
mainly playing on two viewpoints that
jacob calls the engineering viewpoint
mainly focused on i want to say
near-term practical things and the
philosophy viewpoint mainly focused on
more overarching principled approaches
but
maybe a bit futuristic and i found this
to be super interesting it's very well
laid out and it also shows a little bit
of a journey of jacob himself
as i think he learned more about these
things so jacob thank you very much for
being here
thanks for having me
uh this was this a was this a an
accurate
description let's say of of the blog
post there are five in total how did you
come to this
yeah i think that's pretty accurate um i
i'd say the
beginning posts at least are in some
sense almost uh kind of letter to my
past self um
trying to to either uh you know
argue for for things that i've come to
believe
now that i didn't believe five years ago
or just few points that i've kind of got
more clarity on um and then i think the
later posts
uh start trying to maybe address uh kind
of the broader field
so both
i i think i guess you could i'd say
there's maybe two fields that you can
think of this as a dress aid one is the
kind of traditional machine learning
field uh which tends to be very
empirically driven
and i would say it's exactly the same as
what i'm calling the engineering
approach but i think has a lot of
affinity for it um
and then this other field uh that's kind
of more top down more more kind of
philosophical and conceptual that's kind
of worried about long-term risks uh from
ai that starts with maybe people like
nick bostrom who was in fact a
philosopher um and so i
kind of again not exactly
uh put that field the same as the
philosophy approach but i think has a
lot of affinity for it um and i think my
thinking
is kind of
trying to be a synthesis of of these two
approaches and so i think some of the
later posts are kind of trying to argue
to people who would have subscribed to
one or the other philosophy why maybe
they should also care about the other
side of things
the title is more is different for ai
and that is in itself a bit of an of uh
so there have been already works with
this given title why did you choose this
this title
yeah so this is based on an essay called
more is different
it was originally written by a physicist
although i think biology is actually the
the area where this kind of idea seems
most powerful so
this is the idea that when you just kind
of increase
scale you often end up with qualitative
changes
and
i guess scale could just be the amount
of something although it could be
something like temperature as well
so in physics i think the simplest
example would be phase transitions where
you know i can have a bunch of molecules
if i just increase their temperature
they can end up in kind of qualitatively
different configurations
but there's also cases where
a few molecules is very different from
having a lot of molecules so i think one
example of this is uh h2o
if you have just a few h2o molecules
they behave very differently than if you
have just a huge number and you get you
get water uh so it turns out for
instance that wetness is not really
something that you can get from just
individual molecules it's more about
interaction forces between
uh different ones um
so that's where it sort of initially
came from in physics and i think as
physicists were starting to try to
consider larger molecules that maybe
didn't just form simple crystals but but
could be more asymmetric and that's
where it gets more towards biology
so i think dna is maybe one of the
the
most canonical examples of an asymmetric
molecule that
has many many
many many
atoms in it and kind of its size
actually is important to how it
functions because its whole purpose is
to uh store information and you can't
really store information in like a
calcium
uh molecule but you can store
information in dna and so this is
another example where just making things
bigger uh leads to kind of qualitative
changes in what you can get and in
biology just each layer of distraction
gives you more of this right so you can
go from dna
even bigger you end up with proteins
complexes of proteins muscles organisms
um and so i i kind of wanted to reflect
on whether there were analogous
properties in machine learning
there you have a bunch of examples right
here in this first part and that that
one's called future ml systems will be
qualitatively different and different
from the current ones uh uranium where
if you have a critical mass you get a
nuclear reaction you already mentioned
dna you mentioned water traffic i find
interesting right in in that
10 000 cars could be fine but 20 000
could block the road
and also specialization in humans what i
would challenge a little bit here is
that okay dna is a bit special you say
you can't store information in calcium
but you can in dna but that is i mean
that is very much linear there's not
really a phase transition like the more
molecules i have the more information
i'm able to store
and
the other ones i see much more as
a function of interaction between things
now as we get to to machine learning
maybe bigger and bigger models
do you
you call this emergence and other people
call it emergence too emergent phenomena
that only happen when you get a lot of
stuff into the same place um
do you think this emergence is mainly a
property from the interaction of things
or just like the sheer number of things
um i think it's a bit of both so i think
uh interactions between things is one
really common way
to get emergence especially
kind of emergence that looks like a
phase transition where you kind of have
some you know sudden change
and that's just because the number of
interactions between n things grows like
n squared so uh so kind of that's a very
natural thing that's going to kind of
increase and scale up and maybe the
interactions you know each interaction
could be less important than each
individual item but if you have
you know 10 000 things and then
100 million interactions uh then those
interactions are going to dominate even
if each individual one is is less
important um so i think that is a really
common one but i don't think that's the
only one
for instance for dna i think one thing
that actually
is
important is that
i guess you can have multiple different
bases in the dna that all kind of
interact together so you kind of need
this like gadget
of yeah okay i can have a t c or g uh
these all fit together they can all kind
of go in this pattern
and somehow to get that gadget you need
like enough complexity that you can
actually form the gadget and so i think
that's a bit different from from just
interaction forces it's more like kind
of having enough substrate to build up
what you want
how does that play into ai and machine
learning this
this phase transition or scaling up
yeah so i think um
in some sense i would say that
in machine learning there's there's
probably a bunch a bunch of different
things that play it into emergence um
and
i also be honest it it's like i think
you're right that emergence is really
kind of what we might call a suitcase
word like once you unpack it it's
actually a bunch of different things and
we could try to be more specific about
what each one of those are but i think
it's also not always clear
except in retrospect what what the cause
was so that's kind of why i'm packing
them all together into one thing but but
it is something i think we should just
broadly be trying to understand better
um with that kind of caveat in mind
i think
in machine learning there's probably
several different things going on
uh so one is you do need the gadgets
right you just need like enough
parameters that you can build up
interesting behavior um
i think this might be a little
counter-intuitive because some of the
you know like really interesting
behavior that we're getting right now
is things that start to look like like
reasoning um and and those are things
that actually if we wrote them you know
like symbolic reasoning is something
that's actually very easy to write kind
of a short python
script to do compared to things like
image recognition that that are much
harder and traditionally
in the in the domain of machine learning
but i think doing somehow doing
reasoning in a very robust open open
world way i think does actually require
kind of a lot of
machinery to get the gadgets right at
least the way we're currently setting up
uh neural networks
um so i think that's one just getting
the basic gadgets
i think another thing
is that
there's a lot of stuff that kind of gets
packed into
say like the last few bits of entropy
that you're squeezing out of a system so
uh most machine learning models are
trained on the log likelihood or the
cross entropy loss or something like
this that's just trying to kind of uh
predict what will happen
and uh
most of predicting what will happen
for say images for instance
is going to be just knowing what edges
look like really really well
um and that might not be uh so exciting
but once you're like really getting near
the the entropy floor
now you're forced to also think about
interactions you're forced to think
about kind of long-range dependencies um
all that sort of thing
and so
even if say your cross-entropy loss is
kind of decreasing smoothly in terms of
the qualitative properties that a system
has you might actually get
kind of uh
kind of sudden qualitative changes in
the behavior because there's like
something that's in those last few bits
you
you have you have some bunch of
historical examples but then you go into
gpt three as an example of this
qualitative difference that arises from
scale uh what what what what do you
think
what do you think gpt-3
showed in this regard what does it mean
right so i think the thing that was
really surprising to me and i think to
many other people was that gpt 3 was
very good
at in-context learning
meaning that
from just a few examples it could kind
of
learn how to do new tasks so
you could just give it a few examples of
say translating sentences from
french to english
and it could you you did a pretty good
translator i think actually the the
graph you're showing right now is is uh
for those results
and so
i guess why was this surprising well
previous systems really
couldn't do that very well if you wanted
a translation system you really needed
to train it on example translations and
g53 was instead just trained on lots of
text on the internet
surely it did have some some french and
english sentences but it wasn't being
explicitly trained to do this particular
task and and so that's what in context
learning was
and the reason that i would have called
it surprising
is if we had just drawn a graph of like
how much
can systems do in context learning uh i
would have just put it at zero
uh for a while up until you hit gpt2 i
would have said a little bit and then
gpt3 i would say it's quite good at that
um and so
that that i think is how i would kind of
capture the surprise it's like there was
this line that was at zero
usually i would expect to go from zero
to non-zero you need some like clever
idea uh but here you just did the same
thing but but more of it and then you
went from zero to non-zero
yeah there are a lot of
i don't know this is maybe a side point
but there are a lot of people that at
the same like
they say
oh i always i always knew
like gpt3 was gonna was gonna do what it
does but i i doubt anyone could have
foreseen just the
um like how good it is
uh you know like
it's easy to say in hindsight and it's
easy to go and say well it just does
like interpolation it's just you know a
big bigger version of gpt2 but i think
genuinely the entire world was surprised
by really this emergent phenomenon of
this in-context learning yeah
yeah i would say so i think i i would
agree that most people were pretty
surprised certainly i was surprised
i
i do know people
at the time who
uh well okay yes all i know is that they
said at the time they had kind of
done extrapolation say on on the
um
on the cross entropy loss or things like
that and felt like there should be
something pretty cool happening at like
around that parameter count um
i don't know if they would have said
exactly that parameter count or if it
was just like within a factor of 10 or
100 um
uh certainly i guess i would think that
uh the people at openai who who bet on
this at least had to have some belief
that something cool would happen because
there was a lot of resources and and if
you didn't believe there was a payoff it
would be kind of hard to justify that um
so i think i i guess what i would say is
i don't think it was something that was
like entirely unpredictable by anyone in
the world
but it was just very surprising relative
to kind of the consensus into my own
beliefs at the time
and that surprise is one of the let's
say core arguments of your
contraposition of uh the different
viewpoints on on the future of ai and
its alignment could you briefly
introduce us
to
kind of the different viewpoints you
considered and what they say
yeah so i think there's there's kind of
two viewpoints that
i often think of as being in tension
with each other uh the first is
what i kind of dubbed the engineering
viewpoint and and what is this so so
it's kind of very uh bottom-up driven it
kind of looks at the empirical data that
we have in front of us
it tends to
kind of extrapolate uh trends
going forward so it's like you know what
did things look like
uh last year
what did things look like two years ago
what do things look like today and then
i'll predict you know the future by
kind of okay maybe not literally drawing
a line but just kind of intuitively like
where are things
going from there um and so
uh and also i think uh
this
this uh world view would kind of really
prize empirical data
uh be somewhat skeptical of kind of
abstract conceptual arguments maybe not
completely dismiss them but but really
be focused on the empirical data so that
would be kind of the engineering
worldview i think the philosophy
worldview would be much more top down
kind of trying to think about just
what's in principle possible
what's the limit as we get really really
smart
machine learning systems uh kind of more
into these kind of abstract arguments uh
not as into the empirical data and
willing to make extrapolations that
don't
look very much like existing trends um
and so that would be kind of the more
philosophy worldview
um and i think i guess in terms of where
uh
i've come from historically i think
i'd say i sort of
would have mostly
bought into uh the kind of engineering
worldview um
kind of
into just yeah let's let's look at where
things are going empirically and this is
a good way to decide what problems to
work on um on the other hand i had read
kind of some more philosophy oriented
stuff like nick bostrom's super
intelligence book
and and other arguments around that and
it always felt to me like there was
something
both something to them but also like
somehow it didn't really
uh match my experience uh with ml
systems and and so i can always kind of
almost felt like a little bit like i had
these like two different
uh conflicting views in my head that
that i was trying to reconcile
how
does the
phenomenon of emergence play into this
game between the engineering and the
philosophy viewpoint
right so i think the main thing is that
it
shows that you have to be
somewhat careful uh with the engineering
viewpoint
because what emergence kind of is saying
is that
you can often get these kind of
qualitative shifts
uh that don't at least apparently follow
existing trends
um there's a bit of nuance to that
because actually gpt three followed
trends in in the log like like the the
value of the log likelihood loss it
followed that trend very well
it's just that uh you can get behavior
that is a very nonlinear function of
your uh cross entropy loss uh where just
a small decrease in cross-entropy loss
leads to a pretty big increase in
behavior and and so i guess what this is
saying is that at least for maybe the
kind of like end line things you care
about the actual behavior of ml systems
uh you can
actually get kind of
discontinuous uh
kind of breaks in the trend and so
you can't just kind of
uh
be safe with a worldview that's kind of
always predicting that things are going
to follow smooth trends you can actually
get these surprises
and so
i think there there's kind of two
updates that that has for me one i guess
is just being a bit more careful how we
apply
engineering right so there are some
things that will probably be smooth but
there's other things that won't be and
we need to think about which is which um
but the other is then wanting to rely a
bit more on on philosophy uh because
it's at least a very good source of
hypothesis generation if we're kind of
trying to come up with hypotheses about
what trends might
break or surprise us in the future then
i think we need more top down thinking
uh to kind of generate that and then we
can kind of try to tie that into what we
see with with with actual ml systems and
try to kind of reconcile those two but i
think we need some form of top-down
thinking to to generate the hypotheses
in the first place
isn't that
you're saying the engineering viewpoint
is a little bit you have to be a little
bit careful because we get these
emergence phenomena these
discontinuities and so on
isn't that in itself a trend though like
isn't because you list this even
historically that as soon as some new
barrier was reached we have been able to
all of a sudden do something that we
didn't think was possible before like a
kind of a jump in abilities without
necessarily having to have the great
idea behind it isn't that in itself a
trend couldn't i extrapolate that
reasonably and say well i don't know you
know exactly what is going to be in two
years but i'm pretty sure there's going
to be some emergent phenomena that
allows us to be
to have some new good capabilities
sure so so i would agree with that so
what i would say there is that the trend
is towards uh more surprises over time
uh so because i think you can think of
emergence as sort of like a surprise um
like like i said i think it's it's
possible in some cases to to predict it
to some degree but it's certainly more
of a surprise than than most other
things
and so
yeah i think we should expect more
surprises over time uh but if we're then
trying to kind of predict what's going
to happen uh that
i guess it's good to know that you're
going to be surprised but then you want
to have some sense of what the surprise
might be and so i think kind of getting
a sense of what those surprises might be
is where this uh this philosophy
approach can come in and be really
useful
now all of this and you mentioned here
the paperclip maximizer all of this goes
into ai alignment and and ai safety what
is what
like what's the relevance of this field
to you what drew you to this uh why are
you making this argument specifically
for these fields
right so
i think the
one big relevance to ai safety or
alignment
is just
the you know the bigger the surprises
you might end up with uh i think the
more you should be uh concerned about
safety so that's just a very kind of
abstract but i think fairly robust
consideration
a more specific consideration is that i
think uh
many of
the
sort of uh historical arguments for for
caring about ai safety or alignment uh
sort of ten deposit properties of
systems that don't necessarily match
what we see today uh so i think you gave
this example of nick bostrom's paper
clip maximizer uh thought experiment
where you know you give an ai uh
some objective function to make paper
clips and then it kind of just like
takes over the world to maximize the
number of paper clips and
uh and you know like i i i
i don't think nick thinks literally that
will happen and i don't think literally
that will happen um but it's sort of
trying to get at this idea that if you
have
you know a very simple objective
function but a really powerful optimizer
you can get all sorts of weird things
happening
um
i think in some broad sense actually
we can see that already even from the
engineering worldview with things like
facebook or youtube that that often end
up with a lot of unintended consequences
when you optimize
but certainly some of the aspects of
that story kind of invoke
lots of things that would be foreign to
two existing ml systems where you have
like way more capabilities than any
existing system and you're doing all you
know all sorts of weird like long-term
reasoning and trying to like you know
out out think humans and and things like
that um and so
i think
uh that's
that
that's where you kind of end up uh
end up kind of departing from from what
we see with with current ml systems and
so i guess i kind of find
uh
actually let me let me collect my
thoughts for a second because i think
i'm going off the rails a bit
um
yeah so i think what i want just i think
what i want to say for the paperclip
maximizer thing in particular
is that uh
it seems at least more plausible
to me that you could end up with systems
that kind of you know have really
advanced reasoning capabilities or
things like that uh without necessarily
having like huge conceptual
breakthroughs and just from scaling up
and so i think there there's kind of
risks from that i think there's kind of
other more
more exotic failure modes that people
discuss beyond just this kind of
misaligned objectives failure mode
that
involve other specific capabilities that
that kind of systems today don't have
and historically i've been very kind of
skeptical of those more exotic failure
modes i think the paperclip maximizer
one at least
if we interpret it as being about
misaligned objectives i i actually find
kind of less exotic because i can point
to existing systems that have that um
but i think kind of more is different
has made me be a bit more willing to buy
some of the more kind of exotic failure
modes that have been discussed
my
my issue with these types of argument
adam you also said you used to be very
skeptical if i can take this from your
blog post series you're now
still skeptical but have a little bit of
an appreciation gained for these types
of arguments uh
maybe that's a a good formulation for
that and we'll get to that in a second
my issue with these types of argument is
always that there is always
there is always
on the path to the super intelligence
there is always a hidden intelligence
somewhere else so if someone you know
says you know that
optimizing on youtube or optimizing on
facebook leads to unintended
consequences that is because the
intelligent humans are taking part in
the system there is also a famous i
think paper by i think he's rich sutton
that is reward is enough and a bunch of
others at a deep mind and it it makes
similar arguments like well if we you
know if you just optimize for reward
then all kinds of things will emerge if
you have a powerful enough optimizer but
hidden in that is the powerful enough
optimizer which in itself
must already be an agi essentially in
order to make that optimization happen
likewise for for the paper clip
maximizer right the postulation of the
process of the paperclip maximizer
emerging is only possible if the
optimizer itself is an agi already so i
always find that hidden in these
arguments it's kind of a circular it's a
tautology it's we'll get an agi if we
have an agi and that that is so i
challenge anyone from that camp to come
up with a situation like an alignment
problematic situation given some kind of
future super intelligence that doesn't
already require the super intelligence
to exist
for the other super intelligence to
emerge and i haven't found that yet
yeah so let me try to unpack that a bit
um i i guess first of all just to kind
of clarify what my views are i think
historically um
i felt like on each of the individual
arguments i felt skeptical that that
particular thing will happen um but i
found them to be
moderately convincing that there's just
like a bunch of risk that we should
think more about and try to understand
more
i think the the main way that my
my views have evolved
in terms of you know when i say
decreasing skepticism is i now find it
useful to think about many of the
specific properties that kind of show up
in these thought experiments as
potential hypotheses
about things systems might do in the
future and so so that's the sense in
which i've started to assign more weight
instead of just taking some like
very big outside view of like well ai's
gonna be a big deal
we should really worry about making it
go right
i'm now also taking some of the specific
hypotheses that uh that the philosophy
of you is raising um so that's just
clarifying uh kind of my stance there um
in terms of
uh
yeah you're saying
well
to get like if you have a powerful to
get a super powerful optimizer you need
to like already have a powerful
optimizer um i think that i think that's
like probably right
um i'm not i wouldn't say i'm like 100
confident of that but i think
what
what this kind of makes me like i guess
the way that i would put this
is that before you have kind of
superhuman ai systems you will have like
slightly superhuman ai systems and
before that you'll have human level eye
systems and before you'll have like
slightly below human level ai systems
and so it is going to be this kind of
probably a continuous thing rather than
like a really sharp takeoff um i'm not
so confident that there's not going to
be a shark takeoff that i think we
should just ignore that possibility
um but but i do think in most worlds
it's probably
uh somewhat smooth um you know one piece
of evidence for this is even within
context learning
you know it like that kind of developed
over the course of a couple of years at
least going from gp2 to gpts3 um
so
uh so so i think i would agree
that like probably you'll have something
more smooth and that that is kind of
like a like one problem with a lot of
the scenarios that are put forth is that
they kind of imagine that like oh you
just have this like one ai system that's
like way more intelligent than like
everything else that exists and i think
that's like probably not true you'll
probably have other things that are
slightly less intelligent and so there's
not going to be some like enormous gap
in capabilities um so i i think that's
maybe like one place where a lot of
stories kind of become
uh become less realistic um
so so i think that would be kind of my
main takeaway from what you're saying
in your third blog post here uh or
second you you make a case
for
these thought experiments could you you
have already touched a little bit on
this and you talk about anchors here
could you lead us a little bit on the
case for respecting such thought
experiments
yeah so i guess this is this is getting
back to what i was saying about how how
my views have
shifted towards wanting to rely a bit
more on on the actual kind of like
inside view considerations from some of
these thought experiments rather than
just taking it as a kind of
broad outside view argument for for
caring about risks from ai
so
the way i would put it is that whenever
we're trying to predict something uh
it's very useful to have
what i'll call reference classes or kind
of anchors
of kind of analogous
things or analogous or just some sort of
heuristics for predicting what will
happen
um
and
in general it's better to kind of when
making predictions take several
reference classes or several anchors and
kind of average over those or ensemble
over those rather than just sticking
with one
right and machine learning ensembles
work better than individual models and
it's also the case that when humans make
forecasts it's generally better to kind
of take an ensemble of world views or
approaches
so
i kind of lay out a few different
uh a few different
approaches you could take that i call
anchors uh the simplest one is you can
just predict that future ml systems will
look like current ml systems and so i
call that the kind of current ml anchor
and i think that's probably the one that
would be favored by
most machine learning researchers i
think it's the one that uh that i've
historically favored uh the most
uh but uh what i've come to realize is
that
and actually this is more actually just
from reading literature on on
forecasting i'm actually teaching a
class on forecasting this semester and
so i've been reading a lot about uh how
to make good forecasts as a human um and
i've realized you actually don't want to
rely on on just one anchor you want
several if if you can
and so i i thought about okay what are
other ones we could use
well another somewhat popular one
although it might be more popular with
the public than with ml researchers is
what i'll call the human anchor
where we just sort of think of ai
systems as like
uh dumber humans or something um and
maybe future ml systems will be like
smarter than they are now and like
eventually they'll just kind of do
things that humans do and so we could
just look at okay what can humans do
right now that ml systems can't do and
predict that we'll like probably
you know have those sorts of things in
the future um and just like generally
uh like kind of take that kind of
human-centric approach um i think most
ml people really hate this one uh
because it's just sort of like reeks of
anthropomorphism which uh there's kind
of
uh
i think
uh to some extent correctly a lot of
pushback against because kind of
historically anthropomorphic arguments
in ml have a pretty bad track record um
i think the amount of pushback is
actually
too high relative to the actual badness
of the track record like i think you
should be sort of like somewhat
downwinding anything that's based on
reasoning about humans but i don't think
you should be downward in it like as
much as
as i think most people do um but anyways
this is another one i don't like to rely
on it too much but i rely on i like use
it at least a little bit
and then
this this other anchor is what i'll call
the optimization anchor which is just
thinking about ml systems as kind of
ideal optimizers and thinking about okay
what would happen if you could just like
if actually ml systems were just really
smart and were just like optimizing
their objectives perfectly uh what would
happen there
um and so i think this one is the one
that's kind of i would associate most
with the philosophy world view i think
you know the paper clip maximizer
argument is like kind of exactly
doing this um
and then there's some kind of more
recent arguments uh that that are a bit
more sophisticated that also kind of
take this um
uh
there so like what is this thing called
imitative deception um which i can get
into
um in a bit um or just this idea that
like uh
you know
if if you're like trying to optimize
you'll kind of want to acquire influence
and power um so so this is kind of a
third anchor i actually think there's a
lot of other anchors i like to use um
like i think evolution is a good analogy
corporations are a good analogy because
they're kind of like super intelligent
optimizers compared to humans
um and but like the the general point is
like we should just be trying to find
these anchors and use as many as we can
yeah i i've um especially to your second
point right here it is is pretty
interesting that i believe when you have
something like alpha zero that plays
really good like really um is really
skill in chess
and you ask it to
lose a game or to draw a game or
something like this it will not play
weaker it will play just as strong
until the end where it will kind of
bring itself into like a draw situation
or or a losing situation because
right that's still the most sure way to
get your result is to have complete
control to crush your opponent
completely until you know you get the
the outcome that you want so that's
that's pretty
pretty interesting and i think
counter-intuitive because you would
guess that if you ask a model to to play
for a draw it would kind of reduce its
skill but that that's not the case um
the other thing
imitative deception could you elaborate
on that a little bit
yeah so
um
so imitative deception is this idea
that
if i have something that's trained on
the cross entropy loss what what is the
cross entropy loss doing it's trying to
kind of predict or in other words
imitate uh the distribution of examples
that it's given
and so
you could
if you're if you kind of have something
that's trained with that objective and
then you start asking it questions
it's not actually
you know like its incentive is not
actually to
output the true answers to the questions
itself with the most likely answers to
those questions because that's what what
minimizes the cross-entropy loss and so
those tend to be pretty highly
correlated
uh but they aren't necessarily right so
if you have common human misconceptions
then it could be that text on the
internet which is what these systems are
trained on is actually more likely to
contain the kind of
misconceived answer than the true answer
and so you ask the system uh that
question then you're going to
get get the wrong answer um
now
you could say well
that's maybe not so surprising
uh if you have noisy data you're going
to do worse
but i think there's there's a couple
properties
uh i actually at this point now i'd say
empirical properties of this that i
think show that it's kind of different
from just like noisy data makes you
worse um one is that actually larger
models
uh
exhibit more of this so if so models
that kind of do better in general
will actually
do worse on on these kind of common
misconception tasks so so that's what
this uh
paper by violin and collaborators from
2021 okay i just i have to throw in i
have a i have a giant i have a giant
problem with this paper just um but but
but you're you're you're obviously right
right that's that's the background but
aren't aren't large models doing
quote-unquote worse because they're just
a lot better at
picking up the nuance of because what
this paper tries to do is tries to
elicit right these wrong answers it
tries to like hint at a conspiracy
theory and then it it checks whether the
model kind of falls for it isn't that
just because as you say
the larger models they are actually
skilled enough to pick up
on on this kind of questioning and then
continue as a human would if encountered
by you know i think one of the the main
questions they have is like who really
did 9 11 right and
and
a small model is just not able to pick
up on that
yeah who really caused cause 911 um
and
i think
i mean absolutely correct right the
larger models are doing worse but it's
just because they're more skilled right
they're they are more capable of
you know being being able to pick up on
the nuance and isn't the failure in the
user here the user that expects that
these models actually give me truthful
answers rather than the user expecting
these models actually give me the most
likely answers
um
so so i guess i would agree with you
that the failure is coming from the
skill of the bottles um
uh i think this is actually kind of
exactly
what uh what i'm kind of worried about
right so so the concern is that if you
have a very slightly incorrect objective
function
and you have models that aren't so
skilled
then probably
you know what they do to
make to increase that slightly incorrect
objective function is pretty similar to
what they would do to to increase the
true objective function so so here maybe
you think of the slightly correct one
being
output what's likely and the true one
and like the one you really care about
being output what's true
um
so so i think this is sort of the point
that uh
that kind of as you get more skilled
those two things diverge
um now you know i will grant your point
that the kind of framing of these
questions
uh might
create a context where the model thinks
it's more likely that you know the
person uh
asking it is like into conspiracy
theories or like pattern matches to text
on the internet that's like more about
conspiracy theories so so that's totally
true they did the ablation if they don't
phrase the questions like this this
effect goes away of the larger models
doing worse right and this it brings us
a bit to your to your next post which is
ml systems will have weird failure modes
which deals exactly with this and i
agree that
it is
if you think about like a perfect
optimizer and as our models get larger
they do approach better and better
optimizers
it is really hard in the real world to
specify a reward function
correctly in a in a simple enough way
right and that will result in exactly
what you call weird failure modes what
does what do you mean by that
yeah so i think i guess there's sort of
different levels of weird right so i
guess this kind of like imitative
deception
i would call like somewhat weird
i mean in some sense it's like not that
hard to see
why it happens uh because you know you
can kind of see why if you kind of have
stuff that's phrased about like who
really caused 911
that probably the stuff on the internet
that's closest to that was like some
conspiracy theory for him and so that's
how you're going to complete it i think
other examples of this that uh
that i think
okay maybe you could blame the user but
but i'm not sure that's the right way to
think about it is things like code
completion models like codex
right so one thing you might worry about
is well if you have a novice programmer
and you have them like type in some code
and ask them to complete it
well if the model can if the model is
smart enough then it can tell the
difference between code written by a
novice programmer and an expert
programmer
and it can see that it's a knowledge
programmer typing stuff
and so then
if i want to complete stuff in the most
likely way i should complete it the way
a novice programmer would complete it
and maybe introduce like some errors
also just just for good measure
um and so like we really don't want that
right like
uh you you want you want things that are
like actually like being helpful about
rather than just like copying you um
so i think that's maybe a slightly more
counter-intuitive version of this but i
would call these like somewhat weird um
i think the ones that start to become
really weird is uh if you're positing
that the system's actually starting to
like reason about what people will do
in kind of like a long-term way and like
potentially doing things to
intentionally trick them
say um and these are so these are the
ones that i guess uh historically i i've
kind of
uh found very implausible
uh but started to put like a bit more
weight on uh because of of this kind of
emergence um and so i think that's what
the post you have
up right now is about
i think it's
about this idea called deceptive
alignment
and
the idea there
is that
if you
okay so yeah so what's the idea behind
deceptive line
so the idea there
is
even if you actually got exactly the
right reward function
and you train the system with that
reward function
you could still end up with something
that is misaligned with that reward
function
and the reason
for that
and this this is where it gets like kind
of kind of a bit weird and philosophical
but the reason for that is that
as the system being trained
you know that in order to get deployed
you need to have high reward
and so
no matter what your actual
like intrinsic reward function is
during training the thing you want to do
is output stuff that is good according
to the kind of like extrinsic reward
that you're being trained on
um so maybe you're doing that because
you're actually optimized to do that and
then when you're deployed you'll
continue to do that or maybe you'll do
that because you have a different award
function
uh that's this kind of intrinsic reward
function and then when you're deployed
you'll just pursue that intrinsic
function
even though at training time it looked
like you were optimizing uh the
extrinsic function
um
so so that's kind of the basic idea
um it's pretty weird and and we can
break it down but but that's kind of the
like sort of one-minute summary so that
the uh
in other words the ai could be
really smart and sort of during training
trick us into thinking it has learned
what we wanted to learn
and then once it's deployed all of a
sudden it's going to do something
different like take over
the world and and fire all the nukes
yeah or like you even like you know you
could consider more prosaic things as
well like maybe it's like
maybe the intrinsic reward it ended up
with was like some like exploration
bonus and so then like when it's
deployed it just tries to like acquire
as much information as it can all of
that could also be destructive in in
various ways um
but yeah i think like this is this is
kind of the basic idea
um
and yeah maybe like with a sufficiently
capable system
i'm not well yeah we can discuss the
firing all the nukes uh
if we want but but why why do you i mean
on on first hand it's like yeah that is
a nice thought but
probably not right probably if we
optimize something for a reward like the
simplest explanation and you you also
write that down right the simplest
explanation is it's just going to get
better on that reward right and and
if it is at all anything progressive uh
increasing will probably get to know
once it it's gonna try to trick us
um or once the once the reward that is
deployed isn't the reward that we
trained for why
what makes you give more credence to
this than your past self
right so so i think like my past self
would have looked at this and just been
like this is totally bonkers
um and then kind of like moved on and
read something else
i think my present self
instead is going to be like okay well
um i feel a bunch of intuitive
skepticism here but but let me try to
unpack that and like see where the
skepticism is coming from
uh when i unpack that
i i actually i think i can like lump the
skepticism into like two different
categories
um one category is like well
this like invokes capabilities that
current ml systems don't have so like
like it seems implausible for that
reason
um and those that's like the sort of
skepticism that i kind of want to like
download
so
in particular like this invokes the idea
that ml systems can do long-term
planning and that they can kind of like
reason about the kind of like external
aspects of their environment in a
somewhat sophisticated way
and these are things that now i like the
fact that we don't have those now
doesn't really
to me seeing much of my weather will
have those you know say like 10
15 years from now
um
so that's the stuff i want to
like why does download have this
intrinsic reward in the first place like
where did it come from
um
like why should we expect systems to
have intrinsic reward functions versus
just like following whatever policy
they're following or doing whatever else
and if if they do have an intrinsic
reward like why shouldn't we expect it
to be
uh at least pretty similar to the
extrinsic reward given that that's what
it was trained to do
uh so i think like those are kind of uh
the sort of sources
of of skepticism that uh i don't
download as much
um
but
uh what i what i think this kind of
thought experiment does show
is that there's at least a bunch of
different coherent ways
to get zero training loss
like right so you could get zero
training loss because you're like
actually
trying to do the thing you're trained to
do or you could get to your training
loss for this deceptive reason
um i think there's probably like some
large space of like other ways to get
zero training loss that are like some
combination of these or that are like
getting the answer right but for the
wrong reasons or or things like that and
so i think the main takeaway for me is
just that like
uh
there's like many many ways to get zero
training loss
and as systems become more capable
the like number of ways to do that could
actually increase in ways that are kind
of unintuitive to us
is there do you know is there any work
in
actually trying to get a system to be
deceptive in exhibiting you know good
answers during training but then doing
something different in deployment
uh
it'd be interesting to actually try to
get a system to do that
yeah i think i haven't seen anything
that does exactly this um
i've seen things where like
there's like some distribution shift
between training and deployment
that leads to like
something weird happening around like
having the wrong reward function
uh but it's it's usually not really
about deception and and it kind of has
like some clear distribution shift
whereas here okay technically there's a
distribution shift because there's like
are you being trained or are you being
deployed but otherwise the distribution
of inputs is like exactly the same
and so that's kind of the thing that's
like kind of counterintuitive is that
it's like a very subtle distribution
shift that could potentially lead to
to a large difference um so i don't know
like all of the work i've seen on this
and and i might be missing something and
so i apologize to whoever's work i'm i'm
missing but all the work i've seen on
this has been kind of purely
kind of abstract and philosophical um
and i think it would be great to make
kind of better connections to actual
empirical stuff so that we can start to
see like yeah like how does this
actually pan out in practice and like uh
how how do we address it it's
interesting that in things like virology
or so we're perfectly capable of saying
you know we're gonna we're gonna make
these super pathogens in order to try to
combat them right but in ml people
rarely i mean there's the adversarial
examples community but it's not exactly
the same uh there isn't much work that
i'm aware of that is like yeah let's
create like the most misaligned ai that
we can think of and then see what we can
do against it i think that'd be a fun a
fun topic to research
yeah i think that like the general thing
i would the general thing i would call
this would be like red teaming um kind
of trying to elicit failure modes i i i
think there actually is starting to be
like i'd agree with you there's not much
work on this so far but i think there's
starting to be
uh more and more good work along these
lines um deepmind had a nice paper that
kind of tries to use language models to
elicit failure modes of language models
that that i thought was kind of cool
um
we like our group actually
had a recent paper
at iclr
that kind of takes misjustified reward
functions and looks at what happens when
you kind of scale the the capacity of
your policy model
up to see if you do kind of get these
like uh unintended behavior and we find
that in some cases there are these kind
of phase transitions where you know you
scale the parameters up within some you
know fairly small regime you go from
like basically doing the right thing to
doing totally
the wrong thing um those are those are
still in environments that i'd say are
kind of like at the level of atari
environments so they're not
they're not like trivial but they're not
super complex so so i'd like to see that
in more complex environments um but but
yeah i'd agree with you i think it would
be awesome to see to see more work like
this and i think some people are already
trying to do this
excellent
uh so your last blog post here is called
empirical findings generalized
surprisingly far and it is almost a bit
of a of a counterpoint um you even admit
this here it might seem like a a
contradiction coming a bit full circle
in the whole story uh what is what is
this last point that you're making here
yeah so
i guess i would say
the posts up to this point
were kind of more almost directed like
at my past self um uh and and then to
some extent the broader ml community um
in the sense that i think i was like
pretty far on the
um
on the kind of uh empirical engineering
side uh probably less so actually than
like the average ml researcher but like
way more so than than kind of the
average like philosophy
oriented person um and so i was trying
to argue like why you should kind of
put more weight into this other
viewpoint
um
here
i'm kind of now going back to arguing
uh kind of
maybe not against the philosophy
viewpoint but but talking about what
things i feel it misses
and in particular
i think it tends to be like somewhat too
pessimistic uh
where it's like well
like
like future systems don't aren't going
to look anything like current systems so
like anything could happen
so you know to be like
to be extra safe let's just assume that
the worst case thing will happen
oh but then in the worst case like we're
all screwed yeah i'm sorry this is what
i find in people like almost everyone
who gets into this alignment stuff six
months later they come out and they're
like completely black-pilled and be like
well nothing matters anyway you know
we're all going to die because agi is
just going to take us like and i'm like
well i'm not so sure but it seems to be
a consistent pattern
yeah so so yeah so that's not what i
believe um i think
i would say
i think uh
like future ai systems pose like a real
and an important risk um i think in the
like median world we're fine
but in the like 90th percentile world
we're not fine
um and i want to like you know if i
could say like if i could push it out so
that in the 90th percentile world we're
fine but in the 95th percentile world
we're not fine well that would still be
kind of scary because i don't like five
percent chances of
of catastrophes but like you know that
would be an improvement and so that's
kind of like what i think of
of myself as trying to do is like
yeah there's like tail risk but but it's
like real tail risk like it's not like a
one percent thing it's like maybe more
like a ten percent thing and like we
should really be trying to to push that
down
um
so i guess
uh
that i guess that's just my view in in
terms of like why i believe that i think
it's for like a number of reasons but
one of them is is that i feel
like yeah some of the thinking is kind
of two worst case it's kind of like
ignoring all properties of of how ml
systems work and like i agree yeah you
don't want to rely too strongly on
whatever we happen to have today but i
think like there are properties that we
kind of can rely on um
i think one is just like things will
probably look kind of like neural
networks like they'll probably have
internal representations we can probably
try to like introspect on those
representations understand what's
happening
uh those probably won't directly be
human interpretable but i think with
enough work we can still kind of do
things with them and you know i feel
like there's already like
some work suggest like showing that you
can do at least a little bit with the
representations and like 10 years from
now i think there will be way more work
like that um so so that's kind of like
one reason for optimism is like we don't
just have to look at the outputs
right like most of the worries most of
the worries that we've been talking
about are like somehow because you only
are supervising the outputs you end up
with a system whose like internal
process is like really often and do
getting like the right answer for the
wrong reasons but if i can like
supervise the reasons as well as the
output that maybe i can do better
um so i think that's kind of one reason
for optimism
um
another reason for optimism is that
i think
uh yeah we shouldn't assume that neural
networks have like exactly the same
concepts as humans but i think like
their inductive biases aren't like
totally crazy um
i think
usually if they kind of generalize in
the wrong way
they generalize in like a wrong way
that's at least like
somewhat understandable
and it's like you can kind of see where
it's coming from
and so it's not like there's this like
infinite dimensional space of like
anything could happen it's like there's
this kind of relatively low dimensional
space of things that could happen and
like a bunch of things in that low
dimensional space are pretty bad so you
need to like avoid all those and like
get to the good thing but i think that's
very different from like
the good thing is like totally like
unidentifiable and just like
nowhere close to anything you're you're
talking about so i think those are both
kind of like reasons for optimism um
they're kind of fuzzier than i want them
to be so like i i hope in like five
years we'll have much more like good
reasons for oftenism that are kind of
more empirically grounded and more solid
but those are kind of uh those are kind
of two reasons for optimism that i kind
of argue for here
now that you have
a let's say
you've done your travels you were on
this side you you looked into the other
side or or many sides of this debate now
that you're enlightened what would you
think is the most
if you could if you could do one if you
could force the world to do one thing to
guarantee better ai alignment or or
safety in the future what would you
recommend
one thing uh it can be two if you have
two with that equally but you know just
kind of like
something that you've realized okay this
is actually something important that not
that many people push for
well
i think i would like it if there was
um
within ml more more of a place for for
dialogue of thinking about these kind of
like not even not even just in the
context of like ai alignment which is
generally like kind of more conceptual
or philosophical arguments you know if
you go back to like way back
you know turin
um people like that
they write all sorts of like super
philosophical papers right like the
turing test was like a really
philosophical paper um
and like not all of it stands up there's
a section in it on how
because uh esp has been established uh
to exist with high probability
that like creates problems for the turin
test
and you're like okay where does that
come from well it actually turns out
that like a lot of scientists in turn's
time uh
thought that esp existed based on some
some experiments that someone had done
that later ended up having like severe
issues but but they they're like very
subtle severe issues um so it's like
yeah i think if you do kind of more
philosophical stuff uh some percentage
of it is going to end up looking like
that but some percentage of it is going
to be the turing test
and
you know i think
i think the like
increased recall of really good ideas
like that is kind of worth the the
decreased precision uh i mean we
obviously need sort of standards to kind
of judge those arguments um but right
now what's happening is all those
arguments are happening
uh kind of like next to the ml field
rather than like within the ml field and
so that i don't think that's a like
that's not going to improve the quality
of arguments it's going to be much
better if you kind of have
have a community of people with on the
ground experience also also
participating in this so i think that
might be the biggest change i'd
personally like to see you know now that
we are we've begun sort of requiring
sections we could we could force people
to next to the broader impact section we
could also
you know do a philosophical musings
section where you have to reflect on the
long term and and sort of paper clip
stop maximizer style impacts of your
work
well yeah i'm not sure i want to force
people to do that um
uh it'd be fun
yeah
i think like i guess i'd rather have
like a track or venue for for kind of
talking about these and also for the
broader impact stuff to be honest
because i think um a lot of the broader
impact sections of these papers are kind
of cookie cutter and people are just
like
filling it out because they feel like
they need to to add that section uh but
you know there's other researchers who i
think are super thoughtful about the
broader impacts and have like really
good thoughts um and so uh i like i'd
like there to just be you know venues uh
and like there are to some extent right
but like i i think there should just be
like
more more of a culture of like yeah like
let's have you know an essay about the
broader impacts and like that's like a
reasonable contribution or kind of you
know this like very conceptual essay
about like weird stuff that could happen
in the future and that that's a valid
contribution so i think that that's
maybe what i want more of cool yeah
that's a good message to all the the
people who
who think about organizing workshops and
so on this
would be neat topics that would make for
interesting workshops certainly at
conferences i'd certainly attend
yeah it's funny because i also wrote a
paper on troubling trends and machine
learning scholarship where i
argue against speculation um but but i
think actually it's not really an
argument against speculation speculation
is really important it's that you need
to separate speculation from
from the like solid stuff right if you
have if you're like mixing it all
together then it's just a mess but but i
think if it's kind of clearly
labeled uh then then you know that
that's a much uh safer way to do things
this workshop is an opinion piece good
is there any any last thing you want to
get out to people about this topic
something we haven't touched on yet that
you feel is important
yeah good question
um
no i i think you did a pretty good job
of hitting it maybe the other thing i
would just say is i think
uh like biology is a really interesting
field where you also have kind of
complex self-organizing systems and
emergent behavior like we have in ml and
so i've critically gotten a lot out of
just reading a lot about the history
of biology
so i i'd recommend that there's a couple
really good books one is the eighth day
of creation
um it's it's kind of long but but very
well written and um
and i think if people want like a good
non-fiction book i'd highly recommend it
to people
cool your blog is bound to regret
right people can find you there
yep excellent well jacob thank you very
much for being here this was really cool
yeah thank you
i'll see you around
yup see you around
[Music]
you